walking up the ramp walk into the
hallway I flash back to when I was a kid
and with the action figures inside
suddenly I had like a big lump in my
throat Brian is doing many unexpected
things and taking characters in new
directions individual stories of these
characters are elevated and made fresh
and new that's what I love about Brian's
approach to the story it's like a real
journey of discovery
is and gentlemen welcome to episode 8
first time shooting with mark first time
Shane with Daisy
[Music]
first time shooting a Star Wars movie
and we got some cool stuff
sad like a dog whimper Ryan's wonderful
personality is all over this phone he
has flaws in other areas I just don't
know about this there's the weird thing
that happens when it's being built and
when you first show up on it here's kind
of over about ropes by at all and then
you get into the nitty-gritty of working
on it and naturally that level of it
goes away and you find yourself just
focused on making a scene work getting
the shots and then once in a while
you're taking a little break and sitting
back then you look around
we get the holy crap mountain again
concentrators works split up by holy
craps
[Music]
okay beautiful very nice guy
you